CARTER MORGAN: This week,
we're talking about AI from A
to Z. I'm Carter Morgan.
And welcome to "This
Week in Cloud,"
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
We created AI Hub
to make it easier
to collaborate in the cloud.
And it's constantly evolving.
More comprehensive labeling
for assets and the ability
to favorite assets you use
regularly are just a few
of the ways.
You might notice a few
changes to the home page too.
Get the full brief
on the cloud blog.
If you're already using AI
Platform Prediction to run
ML models, you can
now take advantage
of continuous evaluation to
keep those models in top form.
We'll assign real
human reviewers
to compare samples from your
models to ground truth tables,
giving you a clear picture of
how your model is performing
across time.
It's all on the tutorial.
Check it out.
Speaking of better
ML models, are you
looking to analyze your
conversational experience
to improve customer
satisfaction and get insights
into top customer queries?
Priyanka Vergadia
has a great post
outlining how you can send
data from your conversational
experience built on Dialogflow
directly into BigQuery
for further analysis.
Go peep that.
Cloud Storage
Platform already makes
it easy to store your data.
But knowing how to
optimize your storage
spend for your specific
needs, that calls
for a little more guidance.
And we've got a great
resource to get you started.
Learn best practices, like
setting up a lifecycle policy.
Then grab your broom and
dustpan and get to work.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
And in the meantime, we'll
see you in the cloud.